bonjour monsieur séguin bonjour maestro
ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir pour
nous de recevoir ici place des festivals
oui al'approche de ce grand concerne en
plein air parc jean drapeau et spa 67
c'est nouveau pour bien des gens pour la
plupart des gens la région de montréal
et pour vous aussi là oui ben moi j'ai
été très honoré en fait qu'on demande
alors qu'est-ce metropolit et à moi de
faire partie l'inauguration ce nouvel
espace
mes parents se sont mariés en 67
l'exposent a toujours fait partie en
tant que montréalais de de notre
imaginaire de notre bagage aussi ce qui
nous ont ouvert sur le monde
alors de d'inaugurer cet espace qui va
permettre encore plus d'événements
culturels et de rassembleur d'avoir lieu
sur l'île notre-dame je pense que c'est
génial mais je suis aussi très curieux
de voir l'espace lui-même il paraît que
la vue est magnifique et je suis certain
que ça va devenir un incontournable dans
notre vie avec une acoustique qui est
différente la vous sortez d'une pratique
à l'intérieur est-ce que vous vos
musiciens votre orchestre vous sortez de
votre zone de confort si on veut quand
vous êtes dans un espace comme ça deux
configurations complètement différente
c'est ce qu'on sort de notre zone de
confort mais ça fait partie de l'adn de
leur caisse titre profitait de sortir de
sa zone de confort
toute l'année on joue non seulement
maison symphonique mais dans les
arrondissements dans des églises dans
des salles
ils ont des salles de cégep des salles
d'université et l'été on a énormément de
concerts on a ce concert au parc
jean-drapeau mais on joue comme à chaque
année sur la montagne de cette année ça
va être le 25 juillet au pied du mont
royal au coin de l'avenue du parc
bon on fait des concerts dans les parcs
un petit peu partout sur l'île alors je
pense que d'aller vers les gens d'amener
la musique dans des conditions
acoustiques sont pas idéales mais des
cons qui sont compensées je prouve par
des conditions de nature et de poésie
c'est très important d'amener la musique
de cette façon une façon différente de
savourer la muse et une musique
classique que vous voulez la plus
présente possible dans ici au québec et
ailleurs dans le monde aussi vous êtes
présents un peu partout
est ce que ces seules la recette la
nouvelle approche qu'il faut développer
pour favoriser ce contact là la
démocratisation de l'accès à la musique
classique
absolument le mot d'ordre ça peut être
démocratisation mais pour moi c'est une
question que chaque chaque citoyen peut
se sentir touché par la musique un vrai
moment de sa vie c'est de la musique
qu'on n'a pas besoin de connaître bien
pour apprécier c'est de la musique qui
peut nous faire rêver qui peut nous
faire vibrer que nous apporter des
émotions
même si on n'a jamais appris la musique
et c'est ce ce contre quoi je me bats et
que leur caisse de la politesse bat
depuis des années cette espèce de
préjugés comme quoi il faut être
reconnaissant pour apprécier alors c'est
vrai que d'aller vers les gens comme on
le fait c'est très bien mais c'est aussi
d'ouvrir nos portes à ce qu'il vienne
aussi au centre-ville ça va dans les
deux sens
[Musique]
et aussi il ya plusieurs aspects qui
change dans la musique en ce moment il
ya les styles de chef d'orchestre et qui
changent vous l'incarnez parfaitement
par les engins de new york
c'est aussi ça fait partie de cette
approche qu'on connaît et loupé c'est ça
ben en fait la musique dite classique ce
musée qu'on a on al'avantage d'avoir ce
grand bagage et héritage de grands chefs
d'oeuvre de mozart de beethoven à chaque
année à chaque époque on peut rajouter
des nouveaux noms au xxème siècle
c'était bartok stravinsky chostakovitch
et au 21e siècle c'est nos compositeurs
québécois canadiens et c'est de plus en
plus évidemment on se veut et on se doit
d'être le reflet de nos sociétés et
c'est injuste que pendant des siècles et
des décennies les femmes compositeur
était mise un peu à l'écart parce que
c'était le contexte de la société et il
faut redoubler d'ardeur je trouve cette
année pour donner une place aux femmes
mais aussi à nos communautés culturelles
avec notamment des orchestres de plus en
plus paritaire yannick nézet-séguin vous
êtes partagés entre montréal
philadelphie new york en demandant un
peu partout à des chefs les plus en
demande
ça va la série est voué souple et par
moments on voit c'est que vous entraînez
souvent oui mais bassong est important
c'est très important c'est vrai qu'il
faut se garder en forme c'est un peu
comme un sportif il faut être
premièrement mon métier lui-même est
assez physique très exaltant c'est sûr
que je veux pas me blesser donc j'ai une
entraîneur depuis des années et je fais
attention mais surtout la musique me
donne beaucoup d'énergie et le fait d'un
chef d'orchestre et travailler avec des
gens avec des musiciens qui eux mêmes se
donne beaucoup
alors c'est vrai que j'ai pas une vie
tranquille dans les avions souvent oui
mais je ne vis
un mail à des employés qui est très très
très stimulante et enrichissante et je
trouve que je reçois beaucoup du public
des musiciens
je donne beaucoup oui mais je reçois
beaucoup et je trouve que je pourrais
vous dire je me suis jamais aussi bien
senti que mettra dans ma vie et on
approche du 20e anniversaire de la
présence de maestro nézet séguin à la
tête de l'orchestré métropolitain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on peut envisager quelque
chose de spécial pour souligner la chose
est ce qu'on peut parler un peu de votre
avenir qu est ce que vous avez dans vos
cartons alors quelque chose de spécial
c'est certain sur un que les 20 ans de
yannick à un métropolitain
c'est ce qui va précéder d'un an les 40
ans de leur caisse on trouve aussi sa
porte alors c'est 2-2 année
d'anniversaire qui vont nous permettre
de nous enraciner encore plus dans notre
ville
et oui on va célébrer de plusieurs
façons on a plein de concerts l'année
prochaine qui sont des occasions
célébration avec des solistes
internationaux et nationaux et régionaux
qui viennent avec nous moi mon avenir je
les dis souvent lors qu'ils sont pro
bowl terre gelée tatoué sur le coeur
alors j'en reste à tout ça reste chez
que de nos jours on peut l'enlever mais
j'ai fort l'interaction
alors pour moi j'ai pas du tout
l'intention quitter leur caisse titres
bolt on est tellement une belle histoire
j'entrevois ça comme pour le reste de ma
vie
[Musique]
pour ce concert de ce soir donc à
l'espace 67 qu'est ce que nous réserve
le répertoire que vous allez offrir
on a décidé de rendre hommage à ce qui
fait l'histoire de montréal
donc le côté francophone avec des
extraits de carmen de bizet du boléro de
ravel aussi donc ça c'est côté
francophone côté anglophone qui est les
variations enigma de hunger donc belle
magnifique oeuvre qui mettent en valeur
leurs caisses
mais aussi on a commandé une pièce à une
mexicaine de canadiennes allaient rendre
à rogers qui nous a recommandé une bien
et qu'il a écrit une pièce spécialement
pour parler des racines de montréal et
entre autres ses racines autochtones
alors c'est un hommage au passé mais
aussi beaucoup dans commence incarne au
présent merci infiniment
c est un plaisir et un grand plaisir
d'être encore rien vu c'est vous ce soir
je vous le promets je reviens souvent
citoyens vont s'amuser avec nous et
c'est gratuit 20h30 merci au revoir